we got this story here let's pull this
one up from the from the new york post
this is just it's just frustrating
hunter biden laptop material entered
into congressional record hey that's
really really good they say material uh
uh from hunter biden's infamous laptop
was entered in the congressional record
at the request of matt gates the florida
republican made the move during a
hearing on oversight of the fbi cyber
division after its assistant director
brian vorde vordran
testified that he didn't have any
information about the hunter biden
laptop which the bureau sees from a
delaware repair shop in 2019 house
judiciary chairman jerry matt nadler
initially blocked gates request but
relented a short time later nadler's
change of heart came after what gates
described as con consultation with
majority staff
i seek unanimous consent to enter into
the record of this committee content
from files from and copies from the
hunter biden laptop nadler responded
without objection
there's a lot of really nasty stuff in
there but the craziest thing is some of
these emails directly implicate joe
biden in his scandal involving ukraine
and kickbacks dirty dealing
well and all of the same people who told
you that this was a baseless conspiracy
theory expect you to trust them on
russia and ukraine yeah
and now i mean they come back one and
jesse smallette two years two years
later and say oh never mind it was real
yeah which exactly yeah yeah no it's
real now even then they won't say it
would like they almost tried to do this
funny thing with it's like it's real now
it's real now but like back then it
wasn't when you were talking about it it
wasn't true now it is you know the
stories where they claim the laptop was
russian from information they're still
up
really yeah they're not corrected
they're opinion pieces masquerading as
fact it's so paranoid how do we break
people out of these this these lies
these manipulations how do you expose
people to the truth and show them the
corruption if well i think if somebody
wants to believe that they're just going
to
the
the topic of russian disinformation is
so hysterical given that this is a
concept which was lampooned for decades
as soon as the cold war ended and even
during the cold war there was always a
very tongue-in-cheek attitude that the
american press and american media took
towards any suspicion of russia but then
as soon as they decided that you should
think russia is a real threat
millions of people started thinking
russia is a real threat even though
weeks ago they had been making fun of
people for even considering the
possibility that russia was a negative
actor on the world stage or that we
should be frightened by them so i mean
if you're able to do that kind of a 180
because the media told you to i'm not
really sure what i can say to you to
convince you otherwise russia is a
threat to i mean to to uh western
dominance and sure i'm global domination
well sure i'm not saying that these
other countries uh in other major
players on the world stage are not
adversarial to us in any way but my
point is it was considered laughable to
say anything negative about russia
remember in 2012 when
mitt romney said that russia was going
to be a large geopolitical foe for us
and he was laughed at by everyone in
media and then in in 2016 we go not only
not it's not as if they started taking
this realistic approach of saying well
russia is a decently sized nation there
are world power maybe we should be
concerned about them it turned into
everything that goes wrong in our
countries because of russia which is
insanely paranoid in a complete 180.
and
it's just another buzzword i mean yeah
like like you know white supremacist
racist homophobe you know it's whatever
it's whatever that that's gonna stick
that that riles people up enough in
their emotions that they don't care what
the truth is i feel this certain way so
i'm gonna i'm gonna express myself and
believe you and attack the other person
who doesn't agree with me it was a
breath of fresh air when the when the
biggest viral the viral story of the day
was that will smith smacked chris rock
yes because i'm just like good
distraction it but it's a good
distraction but uh kind of you know
literally a good one like can we just
back away real quick from being at each
other's throats all the time and just
argue about wwe on on the oscar night
yeah i mean i think my instinct and the
instinct of a lot of people when that
first happened was to say that this is a
distraction there's something important
going on that they don't want us to see
but then you dig a little deeper and you
go what are they distracting me from
something else they were just gonna lie
to me about anyway and i wouldn't have
gotten the truth on yeah i think i'm
getting jaded i don't know everybody you
know when it comes to arguing about
chris rock and will smith it's kind of
just it's relatively nonsensical
when it comes to arguing about what's
going on the war there is a good you
know a a good point in that
we need we need to know exactly what's
going on with with legitimate
information to prevent catastrophe
but for the time being
you know or i should say in this current
time
people will just believe whatever
they're told to believe yeah people on
the left are like the media can lie to
me a million and one times and i will
still believe whatever they say well
because they're not going to the media
to get actual facts they're going to the
media to watch the media forward a
particular narrative and so if they get
information wrong it's actually
inconsequential because they're still
doing their job which is telling me
things that make me feel like i'm a good
and virtuous person for supporting
left-wing causes
it kind of goes back to the i mean
they've almost got the abusive
relationship syndrome yeah where
you know you're going to beat me down
but then you're going to apologize and
i'll accept it and then you're going to
do it again and but you're never going
to do it again but then you do it again
but i love you and i'm afraid nobody's
going to if i don't just keep coming
back for you i hear you but it's it's
but it's worse than that because there's
never an apology dude i'd like flowers
every once in a while you know what i
mean
i should have gotten chocolates have to
rush again at least when the deep state
tried to depose a democratically elected
president no nothing just story blew
over i wonder if there's like a a funny
bit on business models that operate the
same way
they consistently don't do their job but
keep apologizing and you keep hiring
your toilet breaks so you hire a plumber
and he walks in and he's like all right
let me get to it eight hours later he's
like all right well i'm leaving that'll
be you know 500 bucks and then look and
there's just
crap everywhere they have those it's
called hedge funds yeah yeah yeah they
just keep doing it and it's also uh it's
also very true of political leaders you
see this all the time whenever someone's
running for re-election they go the
country still has all of these problems
i didn't fix it in the first two years
or four years give me another four years
yeah
give me more time to not do the thing
that i was supposed to already have done
if any other industry operated the way
the media does just think about
calling your you know hiring
groundskeepers to like mow your lawn
and they leave and send you an invoice
and you walk outside and they didn't mow
your lawn you'd be like okay well they
didn't they didn't or worse still they
mowed we they they moted all awfully and
then they mowed your neighbors and
you're like okay
like hey you guys made a huge mistake
and they go no we didn't yeah they call
you like they're like actually that is
uh you're like hey you guys messed my
alarms like that's russian
disinformation
let me send you snarks article we
actually did a great job mowing your
lawn just against the skags mower i used
but it's funny that we tolerate this
yeah this is supposed to be one of the
most vital services for for a country
and it's just
broken i gotta say though i think we're
tolerating it less more people are
paying attention to it but what's being
done about it yeah i mean i think people
are just not paying attention you know
what it is all right we're about to go a
little bit so you mentioned abusive
relationships and i want to take a
little bit further on that uh analogy
because when you are dealing with
someone who is truly toxic
one of the best things you can do is
just stop paying attention to them
you're probably never going to hold them
accountable you're never going to get
them to admit they were wrong you just
have to remove them from your life and i
think that's what a lot of people are
doing with mainstream media
yeah
it's about time i suppose because
no other industry
gets like fails at their job this
miserably mm-hmm and well i guess
government i was getting ready yeah
it's pretty uh they've set the tone yeah
yeah what what what will white people up
what we'll get people to to finally i've
asked everybody this nothing
people do not get involved in anything
in life until it affects them personally
yeah for the most part that's just the
way it is if we can just go about our
business and just pretend it's not there
put my head in the sand i'll just keep
going on but once like once i was
affected by it personally
i took it more serious and then i i was
encouraged to reach out to people and go
whoa they're lying hey pay attention but
before then i knew they lied but it was
like it's not affecting me so i mean it
is but it's not you know not personally
on a personal
hard for hardcore right to the bone
level and once it does that it's kind of
like drinking and driving it doesn't
bother you just somebody you know gets
killed by a drunk driver yeah and then
you're like oh man that's horrible or
overdose you know my my cousin died of a
of a fentanyl overdose
and it's like took a little blue pill
that she thought was a muscle relaxer
that somebody gave her and wow
i'm sorry so what did it turn out to be
fentanyl oh yeah yeah yeah you just said
that so you know and and
while you put the good fight out for it
it's still not as personal until it
affects you and then you know you just
feel a little different yeah i mean so
speaking of which i i didn't pay a whole
lot of attention to the uh the brianna
taylor case i'm not sure when we wanted
to get into that in your story and and
what you feel we got it we got about we
we're getting there because okay all
right yeah well then on on the thread
that we were just on
your question is what can we do to get
people to wake up to this stuff make
funny cartoons i think making funny
cartoons is one thing but here's the
thing
everyone in this room anyone doing
anything politically related for a
career or talking about that stuff is
completely useless and their job doesn't
have a point if if our audiences aren't
standing up for these values in their
everyday life so one thing that's been
said on this show before by you i
believe and it's something maybe i was a
little too cynical to accept at the time
but i would more or less agree with now
is that with with most people who buy to
the narrative if you were to sit down
and have a half hour long conversation
even a 10 minute long conversation with
them about a lot of these issues they
would come away with a different
perspective not the people who are
ideologically possessed but just your
average person who believes in this
stuff and so the solution is just for
the people who are watching the show and
who believe in what's being said here to
be more willing to have conversations
with people around them and i know it's
frightening i know a lot of people are
scared to do it but there is never going
to be any significant change unless that
occurs
because we're just talking to you and
it's funny because audiences will look
to their preferred political
commentators to talk about this stuff
and what you don't realize is like we
are looking at you guys to talk about
this stuff it's very it's a very it's
it's a two-way street yeah everybody
yeah exactly it can't just be us talking
about this it can't just be us having
this con either these conversations you
got to bring this stuff up around people
you know who can be persuaded i'm tired
of hearing about
secret trump supporters you know secret
trump vote i'm like why was it a secret
why didn't you tell anybody the only
reason
anybody had anything to fear if they
were a trump supporter is because trump
supporters wouldn't speak out exactly no
you had a mix though some trump
supporters wouldn't shut up about it
right flying flags everywhere on their
trucks and stuff i can respect that then
a lot of people were like oh i better
not say anything and it's like just say
it because if everybody did you'd be
fine yeah well we're scared it's exactly
everything it's it's amazing how scared
this country has gotten
just i mean on every level and i don't
know if that's been the course over the
years of you know i remember back in uh
probably 2010 we were in a big meeting
at work and
um one of the higher ups was talking he
was like well you know perception is
reality we can't do that and i was like
oh ho ho ho ho perception is not reality
reality is reality right amen i get what
you're saying you got to be careful how
you frame stuff but
it doesn't matter what this guy thinks
of perception
if if
if tim thinks
if his perception is different than 50
people but we're worried about his
perception so we're not given the truth
then we're hurting the other 50 people
just to please the one and it's just
well that's true it just kept going and
going and now we're where we're at we're
so politically correct everybody's
scared to tell the truth nobody has
thick skin where they can take the truth
yeah and so we just shut up and and then
the loud ones run the country when
people say perception is reality there's
there's a good point being made right i
understand that you know what what you
see kind of dictates what you focus on
and how you live your life
but uh
the problem with the problem we have
with journalists is that they've taken
that to heart and instead of saying i
should seek other perspectives to fill
out the narrative they say
if i say it's true because perception is
reality and my perception is all that
matters so instead of doing any research
and telling the truth or just like what
i think goes i think both of you made
points about the most vocal people
representing the movement and yeah
that's very much a consequence of your
average person who exists within any of
these movements or leans towards those
movements being way too afraid to say
anything
and so unless you want your movement to
be painted exclusively by the folks who
are willing to talk you have to stand up
and say something and that's the point i
really want to stress for everyone i
know i say it pretty often on these
shows but if you guys aren't out there
talking about this stuff there's no
point for us to be doing this thanks for
checking out this segment from the tim
cast irl podcast but if you want to
check out the full show live tune in
monday through friday at 8pm and if you
want more special access content head
over to timcast.com and become a member
your membership helps sustain this
company keep our journalists employed
makes this show happen and you will get
access to exclusive members only
segments of the tim cast irl podcast and
there's a massive library to check out
so again go to timcast.com or tune in
monday through friday at 8pm we'll see
you all there
you